[Applause]
well thank you I wanted to welcome you
to this very special event both those in
the room and those joining us virtually
and watching from other spaces around
the world but particularly I want to
welcome the people who are in learner
and comfortable seats so you're very
much with us I'm Lila Abu LaHood and I
teach anthropology and Gender Studies
here at Columbia and direct the Middle
East Institute
among the many wonderful intellectual
communities that I have the privilege of
belonging to here I want to mention the
most relevant one for today I'm a member
of the faculty of the Center for
Palestine Studies the only such Center
based in an American University
dedicated to the academic
[Applause]
he dedicated to the academic study of
Palestine and the Center's mission is to
foster sustained interchanges among
scholars and students and to advance the
production and circulation of knowledge
about Palestinian history culture
society politics now I don't want to
take too much time away from our
remarkable speakers today but I do want
to first thank those who've helped make
this event possible and I want to single
out Miriam Zuni and Dalia of Zain thank
you at the we have an enthusiastic crowd
it's great at the Center for Palestine
Studies and Miriam is hopefully watching
us in Lebanon I also want to thank my
colleagues Brinkley Messick and Rasheed
Khalid especially for their special
dedication to this event but we're also
grateful to all the staff and volunteers
that you've seen around here who
generously offered their time and
talents and it's a tribute to our
speakers that so many units
enthusiastically joined us as
co-sponsors the institute for research
in african-american studies the
institute for research on women and
gender the Middle East Institute the
Center for the Study of ethnicity and
race the Hyman Center for the Humanities
the anthropology department the center
for international history and the
Institute for comparative literature and
society thank you all now we've all done
our parts because we want to add honor
Edwards sides memory and his legacy and
I want to acknowledge especially his
daughter necklace.i who's here tonight
representing the whole family this is
not the first event in his honor nor
will it be the last but we think it's
quite special and I'm glad that you all
thought so too
Edward Saeed taught at Columbia for 40
years and we feel individually and as a
community that we're part of his legacy
at this university and in the world
Cornel West is now teaching across the
street at Union Theological Seminary and
Judith Butler
is teaching here in the Department of
English and comparative literature and
this is a university that showed great
integrity when Edward was alive in
upholding the principles of both
academic freedom and free speech the
university protected the right of this
extraordinary figure to be both a deep
and original scholar and a public
intellectual and I want to share just
one personal memory at Edwards funeral
at Riverside Church ten years ago I felt
sad as the large crowd hushed and deeply
moved by Daniel Barenboim exquisite
piano offering walked down the aisle to
leave the church and I found myself
walking near my dear colleague Mahmood
Mamdani I told him that I felt this
marked the passing of a generation who
would now speak for us while Ahmed had
passed away in 1999 at the Asia Society
here in New York Edward and my father
along with Dan Berrigan and many others
had mourned and celebrated this most
charismatic politically sharp and
beloved figure two years later my father
passed away in Palestine Edward walked
alongside us in Jaffa with some other
people in this room in May 2001 behind
the coffin of his dear friend and now
two years later Edward Saeed and I'll
never forget what Mahmoud said it's now
up to you but who among our generation
could measure up I thought then and I
think tonight on this platform two of
the most remarkable people of this
generation have stepped forward carrying
the mantle but speaking in their own
distinct voices and from their own
standpoints their critiques of injustice
are clear and principled their moral
vision is exemplary and their
intellectual brilliance is unquestioned
like Edward Saeed they are teachers and
scholars of huge distinction and like
him they're the they're at the same time
public figures who speak out
courageously about the major political
and
issues of our time now when talking
about his work on the question of
Palestine Eduard explained the quote
I've been unable to live an uncommitted
or suspended life I've not hesitated to
declare my affiliation with an extremely
unpopular cause unquote now what I
admire so much about Judith Judith
Butler and Cornel West is they're the
same they do not live uncommitted lives
they're intellectuals and philosophers
who have shaped how we think about power
gender race and justice and the value of
human life and they've not been afraid
to think and talk about the situation of
Palestinians the consequences of Zionism
the violent policies of the Israeli
state and the links between forms of
domestic and international injustice
they have affiliated with an unpopular
cause they didn't have to but in doing
what we New Yorkers are urged to do all
the time now if you see something say
something
I think they've given many more people
that ability to see and to speak and I'm
talking about the next generation so for
me these are two moral and intellectual
Giants of our generation and I know
they're not the same height but I've
admired them since I first met them both
coincidentally in Princeton around 25
years ago and I'm so grateful on behalf
of the Center for Palestine Studies and
everyone else for their generosity in
accepting our invitation to come talk
with us and to each other I know you're
here because you want to know because
you know who they are and you want to
hear them so I won't go into their
accomplishments you have a little flier
with BIOS but to get help get the
conversation started I will turn things
over now to James Sheamus familiar to
some as a brilliant film theorist and
professor at Columbia some is a producer
who's been keeping serious cinema alive
and to others as a screenwriter and
longtime collaborator in the good sense
of Angley who's joined us tonight - he's
also on the faculty of the Center for
Palestine
studies so please join me in welcoming
Judith Butler Cornel West and James
Shamus to talk about Palestine and the
public intellectual in honor of Edward
side
good good evening and thanks Lila let me
briefly lay out the format for tonight's
event meditate a bit on some of the
questions its title might suggest to our
speakers and commence with the first
question let's begin by acknowledging
that this was a very hot ticket and more
on that in a second and that tonight we
are in to borrow a phrase both from
Israeli jurisprudence and from Judith
Butler's recent work a lot of absent
presences so while we will solicit
questions to supplement and continue
tonight's conversation we're going to do
so virtually in the hope that those of
you not sitting with us in low library
will feel the connection we hear
certainly feel with you so if you'd like
to join the conversation tweet your
question to at capital C capital u
lowercase Palestine that's Cu Palestine
using hashtag Edward Sayid
hashtag Edward cited all lowercase come
on it's hip or post to our Facebook
event page Judith Butler and Cornel West
and conversation by the Center for
Palestine Studies at Columbia University
operators are standing by and in about
45 minutes to an hour or so one of them
will discreetly hand me a stack of
questions and comments and if and when
the opportunity arises and the
conversation finds a lull I will share
them with you if however the
conversation feels like it can continue
uninterrupted
I'll hold fire and ask all of your
forgiveness if in advance if we
entertain few if any questions so some
preliminaries to an initial question
prompted by the subtitle of tonight's
event Palestine and the public
intellectual honoring Edward Sayid
I'll briefly break down some of those
constituent parts and in preface to the
conversation it announces first honoring
Edward Sayid this evening takes place as
one of a wonderful number of events
commemorating Edward Sayid and as such
at prompts if not begs the question as
to the uses and reasons for those
commemorations honorific ations and
memorization zand celebrations a couple
of weeks ago in Lerner Hall Edward side
was remembered last week his memorial
lecture was delivered tonight he is
honored it is appropriate under such
circumstances to ask whether and how his
memory is working and how it should be
working now how's it working for us for
you one use of course arises for the
simple conjunction of the name Edward
Sayid with the word
Palestine and here I feel the need to
try to articulate a specific and
particular sense of excitement about
tonight's conversation let's face facts
each of tonight's interlocutors alone is
to use the language of celebrity which
raises his own questions but also feels
somewhat appropriate tonight a hot
ticket
but together in conversation present to
each other this does feel like a moment
an event and the territory occupied or
otherwise where they come together
tonight is well Palestine tonight it
feels as though unlike perhaps and
Edward Syed's day it is not the question
of Palestine rather it is Palestine that
is asking the questions
indeed Palestine is demanding answers
the feeling of that feels if I can put
it that way
significant and exciting then we have
this word public what is a public or to
ask the question another way
what do publics do and what might they
be doing here tonight well unlike let's
say proletariat's or people's or
communities or masses or plebs publics
seem mainly to have opinions they or we
could say have opinions ascribed to them
but for Edward Sayid though the word
public always held out the promise of
his enlightenment origins as the site of
public reason as a place where genuine
truths can emerge that's why for Sayid
there is no need for the category of
public intellectual for the intellectual
is by his definition always public
someone who publishes who comes into
being as such by making representations
to a public as he writes in his
wonderful volume representations of the
intellectual there's no such thing as a
private intellectual the intellectual he
says quote is an individual endowed with
a faculty for representing embodying
articulating a message of view and
attitude philosophy or opinion too as
well as for a public to as well as for
the intellectual represents
paradoxically teaching her public
something in a sense it already knows
but just doesn't know that it knows
teaching it in the Sayyidi inversion the
unknown truth about what it really is
it's a strange role that requires the
intellectual to come it's being wholly
in relation to the public
but to not be the public or even part of
the public to be a representing
representation for Syed the intellectual
stands outside and mainly again within a
nod to his enlightenment heritage
because as Syed writes the intellectual
speech is always on behalf of universal
principles the weight of that universal
burden makes the intellectual anything
other than the usual experts sent out to
manage the public through his or her
expertise Syed's intellectual
paradoxically maintains the social
prestige and authority of the
intellectual class but is as he puts it
someone who cannot easily be co-opted by
governments or corporations and whose
raison d'etre is to represent all those
people and issues that are routinely
forgotten or swept under the rug and
here you see another paradoxical
dialectical leap incites thinking the
public that the intellectual is to
represent to the public is actually the
objected the forgotten the oppressed
that is to say Outsiders who's outside
earnest is mimicked by the intellectual
but now from a position of authority if
not of power heavy burdens to bear which
is no doubt why Syed constantly
references the intellectual as well
crankiness least of all he writes quote
should an intellectual be there to make
his/her audiences feel good the whole
point is to be embarrassing contrary
even unpleasant it's as if for Syed the
repulsion felt by the proper public for
those habitually objected and excluded
must if only is a moment of negative
pleasure be felt also in the presence of
the intellectual I think I speak on
behalf of tonight's public when I say
how excited I am to be here to listen in
on what will I know will be in honor of
Edward Saeed a truly embarrassing
contrary and unpleasant conversation and
let's start it by asking as we've asked
about what memorialization z-- do what
public's do what intellectuals do and
what Palestine does a simple question
you need entertain only by ignoring it
what actually are we doing here tonight
Thanks
[Applause]
how are we doing I'm just blessed to be
here with you my dear sister and to keep
the focus on the rich legacy and witness
that Edwards I eat was able to bear
trying to tell the truth the best of his
fallible yet creative ability and yet at
the same time to inspire so many of us
it's true so many of us don't know what
do you think we're doing hard to hear
all the way oh you missed all of that I
said we're here to bear witness and the
town the truth the memory of my dear
brother Edwards I Eve yeah it's
interesting I was thinking about the
fact that we are memorializing and we're
honoring and yet it seems to me that for
the most part when we talk about Edward
Syed's work we speak in the present
tense and and we have to because it's a
work that was written more than a decade
ago ceased ceased to be written a decade
ago at the same time it it acts on us
and we read it and it has informed it's
it's not only in our present time but
it's given us I think a new sense of
what present time might be how we tell
the story of this time how we understand
ourselves in time and so to honor him is
in part to memorialize him but perhaps
there's a counter memorializing that
happens not by dishonouring him but
allowing the work to live in the present
as we take it up and rethink it for our
own time or for our various times one
thought I have is that there was a point
in his work where he he insisted that
when we look at literature especially
when we look at representations of
Palestine or representations of
dispossession or exile forcible exile
that we we have to pay attention to the
form and he said it must be fragmentary
it must be partial there's no single
narrative we can tell there's no single
motif we can tell and that it must
interrupt certain dominant narratives it
must have the power to interrupt certain
dominant narratives and and that's
interesting because it it opens up the
question if we think about the founding
of Israel in 1948 or the incremental
forms of settler colonialism that were
already in place prior to 1948 that were
in some sense the precondition of that
founding how do we tell that story and
how can that story be taught how is it
taught and of course one crucial point
he made is that the story of that
founding rests upon the forcible
dispossession and exile of nearly nine
hundred thousand people the number of
Palestinian exile zin his time was he
gathered about four million and now it's
estimated to be five and that includes
of course subsequent expulsion Xand dis
possessions but how is it that we tell
the story of that founding and also tell
the story of the Nakba can they be told
at the same time can they be told
together or are we yet ready to think
about the lane
between that founding and not only a
radical dispossession of that time but a
continuing dispossession and a
continuing injustice that has has not
been acknowledged internationally that
has not been addressed adequately that
continues as a traumatic feature of our
present to questions of time how do we
how do we tell the one story with the
other how do we link them we grasp that
link how do we understand that that's
not just something that happened in
history but that it pervades as the
historical time work in which we live I
think that if we begin with the notion
of the catastrophic remember when Edward
at the very end of his life he said I'm
the last Jewish intellect and what he
meant by that was that for him because
he's part of a highbrow secular humanist
tradition and which means the legacies
of Athens and Jerusalem for him one must
begin with the catastrophic he'd be the
knock vow
Palestinians it could be slavery in a
new world with people of color it could
be homophobic forms it could be the
Holocaust sure and it's very rare in the
Academy that the catastrophic is really
dealt with in any rigorous way so Edward
comes along and says well I am a secular
humanist like Hayden white like Eric all
Bach I am a student of Vico aha
and Vito was about what robust
volunteerism militant wheel in the face
of what chaos which is very interesting
on it and it was dissertation ADA wrote
at Harvard under Harry Levin he actually
the major influence of Schopenhauer
people forget about that networked early
work he and I he's talked about that all
the time I was blessed in 1977 I first
arrived here what straight there was
lectures and his lecturing on lucasz
goemon of Raymond Williams Merrill
Marxist literature and so forth and and
we would steal away and have drinks and
think and up and talk about Schopenhauer
because I'm very much open and you know
donto telecourses children how we just
lost belong yes
now forget his name in so many ways but
it was very important because of
Schopenhauer was dealing with human
existence is catastrophic you see now
what happens when you historicism
contextualize a catastrophic structures
of domination forms of oppression and
following Vico agency will not just what
you're going to do about it how do you
understand about how do you understand
it so it word was a rational humanist
you'd always talk about the 1936
essay by a buckle art which is about
surf rationalism he said I'm a sir
rationalist what does the sir
rationalist it's a rationalist who
grounded in passion and your quest for
rationality takes the form of turbulence
of transgression of subversion so he's a
rational humanist in that sense and
therefore when it came to Palestine this
is another the beginning of catastrophe
with dispossession with dislocation with
expatiated expatriation
and then occupation then colonialization
and then resistance even as all of those
are rendered invisible in mainstream
academic discourse not all a mainstream
we had brother Rasheed right here and
his wonderful work day and at recent
exit brokers have deceived everybody got
to read that now because that's telling
the same kind of truth every was talking
about how do you talk about the
catastrophic and talk about the
colonisation talk about the disposition
talk about the the occupation in such a
way that you remain a humanist which is
to say you would talk critically about
that bit of any occupation see if there
were a Palestinian occupation of Jews
but there was I II would be the first
one in line critical of the Palestinian
occupation that's kind of brother he was
my cutter brother he has a moral
consistency about it he has a concern or
refuses the two distinctive features of
this declining American Empire which is
callousness ticket
especially when it comes the poor and
working people and indifference the
criminality indifference the crimes
against humanity he understood the
Palestinian predicament starting in 1948
as a crime against humanity he's
absolutely right about that and we don't
want to come to terms with it and to a
degree to which we don't come to terms
with it it will haunt us in a serious
way but of course he would never he
would never focus solely on that
catastrophe because he talked about
different crimes against humanity the
variety of different crimes it could be
the new Jim Crow right now in the
American Empire that's a crime against
you man we've lost two generations of
young black and brown youth almost
across the board that's the crime
against you meant it will come back and
haunt America divided different ways but
Edward said no I'm in the Academy
Princeton undergrad Harvard grad Rp
black nerd authors asked Mary at
Princeton students go read his senior
thesis on Joseph Conrad and Graham
Greene then read the dissertation or
Joseph Conrad in the fiction of
autobiography his first book that he
wrote on Harry Levine one of the
founders of complet a Jewish brother
from Nebraska then he comes to Columbia
and hears Lionel Chilean the others
waiting to greet him and treating him
very nicely embracing empowering in that
way and then he turns as an electric
powerhouse that he was in his skills to
the catastrophe beginning in 48 and we
begin to tell that story so the question
of who is at words ie America's leading
public intellectual in a lot of part of
the 20th century who is that was ie
highbrow secular humanist who was that
was IE courageous visionary what were
the limitations of f-words IE
oh we got a lot to talk about there to
American popular culture not too
sympathetic he's wrong religion matters
religiously musical as he could have
been wrong
so let me it would be the first one
because we talked about this all the
time he loves that kind of critical
engagement but he had his own blind
spots and he understood following Paul
Daman that you can't have broad scope of
insight without having blindness and
scribe within the framework that allows
you to see that there's an interplay
between blindness and insight that's
true fall mostly you can imagine what
they'll say about the most
philosophically sophisticated
sophisticated social theorist of our day
Judith Butler what you're talking about
the insights and whatever blindness
assisted Judith had to yeah we're not
here to talk about that but understand
I'm different no I
I'm sure I'm about to enact though Oh
that'll be ok but so let's talk for a
moment about secular humanists you know
I didn't know I didn't know Edward and I
thought back on why it is I did not know
him
you didn't wonderful conversation not
what's interesting to me and we did
email briefly when we were both angry at
Lawrence Summers for his ridiculous
claim that to criticize Israel is
effectively to be anti-semitic and and
and so we we had a little virtual
solidarity at that moment but it was not
not not very far before before he died
but I was thinking that at the time say
in the in the 90s especially you know
there were people who are humanists and
then they were post rupture lists or
there were people who were secularists
and then there the rest of us who didn't
really know or maybe had some questions
about that term and um and so it's so we
didn't come into conversation for kind
of petty literary critical reasons right
which now seem rather petty to me
because I I'm just not having those
conversations in that way so I went back
and I thought to myself one what worked
a secular do for Saeed and what work
does humanists do why those terms why
did he feel he needed them what work did
they do that
no other term could do or and I
and I found the following which was very
interesting to me first of all when he
when he talks about the secular he tends
to oppose it to what he calls
fundamentalisms or to religion
understood as the demand for theocratic
rule the theocratic rule okay well okay
I understand that he posed secular
nationalists interestingly so secular
must have a critical relationship to
nationalism right I'm starting to
understand a little bit about what it
does but what it seems to do more often
than not is to name possibilities of
connection or translation among exiled
peoples right you want it to hold out
for that and and he made the claim I
think it was indirectly a claim about
Jews in relation to Israel but it has a
more general applicability that when we
any of us represent our our oppression
our dispossession our our forcible exile
the slaughters committed against us that
we have to not only make that
representation clear but also turn it
around and ask for who for whom else is
that happening has that happened and
also have I or have we this people who
have suffered also caused a suffering
for others and what responsibilities do
we take for it and and you have to ask
those two questions who who am i linked
with in my oppression and have I myself
become an oppressor inadvertently or
deliberately thinking that my historical
victim status makes it definitionally
impossible for me to impress to oppress
others okay so so those were kind of two
obligations that he understood his
obligations of the secular interestingly
enough which suggested that there was a
certain dislocation of the first-person
perspective that has to happen within
what he calls the secular now I
there are all kinds of ways to bring
religion into that picture we could we
could all agree on that we could all
agree that those are values the
translation among exiled people's the
the self reflective moment what have I
myself done not only what have I
suffered what have we suffered but what
have we done how do I put those together
how do I keep those two histories from
being delinked systematically right
which is part of the history of pre and
post Zionism and you know there's a
moment I believe it's in representations
of the intellectual where he refers to
Hanan Ashrawi x' dissertation which I
didn't know about and there she claims
that the Palestinian people are those
whose national experience belongs with
that of meaning alongside or juxtaposed
with belongs alongside that of the
Armenians the Jews the Irish the
Cypriots the American blacks the poles
the American Indians at those terrifying
frontiers where the existence and
disappearance of people's fade into each
other where resistance is a necessity
but where there is also sometimes a
growing realization of the need for an
unusual and to some degree an
unprecedented knowledge and and and this
was for for Sayid a moment to which he
returned time and again so when he says
I'm the last man Jewish intellectuals
like yes but maybe he's the last of the
Armenian intellectuals or maybe he's the
last of the black intellectuals in other
words it's not it's not just Palestinian
and Jewish
it's it's a way of thinking the
Palestinian historical experience in
some kind of conjunction not to say that
they're structurally the same or deposit
an equivalence but to say that there's
some kind of affiliation solidarity
demand for translation that emerges in
and through that kind of juxtaposition
no I will sign on that I will say yes I
will sign on that I don't know if that
makes me a secularist to say that but
for him it does oh yeah I mean
he put much much weight on the secular
in that regard but it was fascinating is
that the only one hand one could argue
that there was a certain knob religious
tone deafness and a narrow sense in
brother Edward on the other hand he
wrote some of the most beautiful
insightful reflections on Kierkegaard
yeah and on on Gerard Manley Hopkins in
beginnings and those are Christian
thinkers there was a Christian thinkers
at the same time you think for example
who some of his heroes were when it
comes to intellectual models Jonathan
Swift yes Tory well what is it about
Jonathan Swift remember his definition
of intention and beginnings is the link
between idiosyncratic view and communal
concern that's the definition of in that
1975 text and what is it about Jonathan
Swift he's wrestling with the
catastrophic especially the Irish
question as what Edmund Burke and others
he's unbelievably magnificently this is
where Harold Bloom and it was there you
come together because with Jonathan
Swift both of them are the towering
satirical writers in ears language tell
it to tubs and so forth who's the other
hero of it words ie Glenn Gould that's
in the late the late style essay right
death with the introduction by sister
Miriam herself which is wonderful in
Michael Wood now what is it about what
does it mean for a secular humanist
intellectual to view a classical pianist
as the model of what it is to be an
intellectual but what does he say in
that essay he says Glenn Gould was able
to bring together a idiosyncratic and
profound subjectivity same theme and
this book was written after he was
published after he died this was a text
he was writing on when he died and of
course the text on what
humanism and secular secular humanism
and yeah you know the text what's the
name like sector criticism as democratic
humanism and democratic criticism
humanism and democratic criticism that's
the last book he finished but he was
working on late style and when you get
the Glenn booties and well been good as
able to bring together a form of
rational pleasure or bringing together
the rational and the pleasurable in a
radically transgressive way that links
idiosyncratic view with communal concern
so he has a consistency in his corpus
now so now what would be exilic about
Glenn Gould everything but he's not
Palestinian he's not black it's a food
so what is it what what what is
exhilarated by Jonathan Swift nearly
everything but he's our right wing Tory
too and it was very critical to that but
there's other elements in his literary
practice in his belt in China into the
worldview that Edward embraces full
heartedly and of course the other hero
was adored oh yeah and Adorno was half
Jewish in terms of you know lineage but
in terms of his practice
if Jew or Armenian or black or gay or
lesbian or working class or whatever is
a metaphor for those who have critical
distance from a mainstream and a
streamlined deodorized set of discourses
that don't want to come to terms with
the catastrophic the underside of that
mainstream then you are Jewish
intellectual or many intellectual
whatever whatever you want to call it
for head but it was it was Jewish
intellectual because he's looking at the
history of Western civilization I mean
look at the history of Western
civilization - persistence of that
catastrophe hunting Jews down and then
the irony of those Jewish brothers and
sisters of a conservative bent and
centrist bent when I told my Jewish
radicals when I talk about Jewish
communist not so much Jewish
left-wingers Jewish conservatives and
centrist in 1948 who engage in a
discourse that hides and conceals
suffering of precious Palestinians as
they undergo dispossession as are
undergoing speciation as they undergo
occupation of the 67 to this very day at
this very moment a level of very very
vicious form of colonization and and for
Edward for him it's a kind of seamless
web with all of the dissonance and all
of the contradictions shot through in
terms of his own self understanding in
this regard he talks about C CLR James
he talks about James ball when you talk
about Malcolm X's yes set and he puts
CLR James and Adorno together absolutely
yes he does yes he does but I guess I
would just add that it's also the
liberal Zionist Jewish community which
keeps that hold up that that keeps that
narrative in place so it's not just
conservative rightfully liberals a
centrist these days okay
it was a centrist but but also
interestingly enough some of the some of
the writings that that that supported
the kibbutz movement also wear them
solidly within settler colonialism no
that's true you know Gabriel Peterburg I
think lays that out in in a pretty
convincing way so we have to wonder
about what it is to think about Zionism
perhaps even in its in in some of its
left-wing modes as being complicit with
with settler settler colonialism even on
the left even with all the left and one
of the discursive problems we've got
right is what do we call the left who's
left
that's right who's left under those yeah
butts left of the left but also what
gets to be called the left which is
still may be part of a colonial project
and and that's and that's where I think
he'd thought intellectual should come to
the fore he called it marshalling a
certain kind of realism alertness he was
especially enraged by inconsistency and
uncaring 'king so that we we don't
simply take you know some of these
political designations as as Givens we
have to ask what work they do what if
face mints they perform absolutely um
but you know I think part of it
at least from my dialogues with brother
Edward is that in the 1980s I mean we
witnessed of course the increasing
bureaucratize ation and corporatization
of the university because that word was
in love with the university he lectured
right here I'll never forget I was
sitting right on the front row he
lectured oh what a title home of the
name of the lecture home he talked about
Columbia University as home and I told
Evan said oh you got to be kidding
really
but he says that in this text too as you
know the university is the most utopian
space in our society now I don't agree
with that I think the Apollo on
Wednesday night actually but up but it
work was invested in the university even
as exilic as he was in his thinking
he loved the university context and he
saw the university undergoing
commodification bureaucratization where
critical engagement was pushed to the
margins as big money more and more
shaped the destiny and the agenda and
the paradigms of the universities
absolutely right about that 20 years
later and and therefore liberalism more
and more was not captive but it was
disproportionately shaped by a career
ISM in which hypocrisy and cowardly mess
because a lot of the liberal Zionist
brother/sister would call Edward and say
oh you know we agree what you talking
about we just can't say that in public I
know why because they were scared
because their careers were at speak
because I didn't want to go against
their friends because it made that
Thanksgiving dinner is uncomfortable if
they told the truth Tony George went
through the same thing at a much lower
level than everyone's I eat I eat of
course had you know you know the
military procured his office
I mean the security at his office we
remember that sister Nasser right
meantime you go see the brothers you got
to go through security check because
death threats and so forth and we know
about the 285 FBI file on his keeping
track of him ever
minute going back to 1971 with Ibrahim
the Grady Brandon one of the greatest
Palestinian towering figures he's
falling bigger sister Jaya to you
beloved mother so that so that the
Liberals I did one undergrad can now
risk either it was just too much oh my
god we're going to tell the truth we
have to really pay a cost you don't say
you have to bear a burden you don't say
I mean I recall in 1982 Everett and I
went down in front of the New York Times
just to get the numbers of how many
focal kill in Lebanon they wouldn't
print the numbers then we had to March
again just to use the word occupation in
the newspaper then they then won't call
it a wall they call it divide deodorize
discourse
they're afraid they're intimidated that
was I eat follow-up our Asia at at line
24 a and lentils apology is free it's on
its Frankie speech it's that what is
what is a cause defamation fearless
fearless sheet unintimidated speech
that's the cause of my unpopularity
that's what Socrates said there were
suggest that's part of my tradition too
I got some plain speech about this
catastrophe of Palestinians luck linked
to the not just the US Empire but linked
to the cowardliness of autocratic Arab
countries who would type a big oil
interests it's not just the pro-israeli
Lobby lobbying a conservative since it's
the big oil dictation that allows for
the Arab complacency and and and and and
and subservience even as they talk about
their concern with the Palestine Mother
Russia she lays this out in problem you
just lays it out clearly it's the truth
I tried to lay it out in democracy where
in 2004 they called me an anti-semite
all the time I said you know what
doesn't bother me
i tells you get marginalized tell the
truth
are you professor of tear that's what
the commentary magazine said right he's
a professor of care for throwing one
Rock but Israeli Defense Forces never
call
terroristic ever by the mainstream
newspapers right
you can kill 434 Palestinian children
within weeks what's happened in January
2009 kill 1,400 ragueneau Obama was
coming into office what he had to say
mr. Obama no comment after what do you
mean no comment those children are just
as precious as those precious Jewish
children in tel-aviv who are being
killed what are you talking about no
comment
Zions legacy makes all of us
uncomfortable deeply so even as we come
back exercising our agency because I
mean again as I said we have our
criticisms of brother Edward we wouldn't
ever want to highlight him in such a way
that he becomes somehow some grand deity
at the death at the head of a Pantheon
that's not the brother Edward I knew no
no not not at all he was wrong on jazz
and a lot of other things but I mean in
terms of what worked the secular what
worked the human I mean our human word
of course Verizon or Latin who mondo
which means burying and every word
begins with v co begins not with a
conception of death abstract death like
high degree begins with corpses
qualitatively different discourse you
begin with corpses as opposed to
abstract possibilities of death and so
at the very beginning of even his his
text beginning just a sense of loss as
hell as Iook he's always concerned about
what is lost and what's left out he's
always concerned about forms of death
did psychic be it social psychological
even spiritual he would like their
language spiritual but I'm injecting
that a spiritual death and that is what
a great humanist thinker does even you
know the critics of of humanism in that
way know they have to come to terms with
death and loss and catastrophe and
oppression and domination in some way
but let me ask you this so since what
what would be your critique though of
Edwards secular humanism well it's just
that when I finally understand what he
wants the terms to do I tend to agree
with him
I'm just like agency and well the agent
the Vico I think is really quite amazing
I think I would have a little bit of
struggle with it do we just create
ourselves or do we just produce
ourselves I think not I think we are
produced very often by forces we don't
really have a lot of control over and I
think there's a kind of tragic structure
to subject formation that that needs to
be thought we are formed in history were
formed in language and culture and power
were formed in traditions we don't get
to choose our parents we don't get to
very often choose many things about the
circumstances not just the circumstances
of our birth but the very sense of who
we are in the sense of the world and
then you struggle within it we struggle
within it to find your place and to make
of yourself what you can but there's you
know how do we think about that struggle
you know he was in a different position
he was worried explicitly and always
about the fading of the history of
Palestine the fading of Palestinian
culture the pushing of Palestine into
oblivion that it would become it would
be something that no one would remember
or that there would be no way to install
the memory to archive it to insist on it
and so oblivion was what he was fighting
against right and being able to remake
that history was also a way of giving
himself a ground being able to make sure
that history remained alive and I think
that's that's really really important
but I think sometimes were born into
traditions that are overwhelm us or
encumber us or against which we have to
struggle and I think probably my own
struggle with my own scientists and and
Jewish formation has been one of those I
mean the question of Palestine actually
made me have to think very reflectively
but what I was born into and what I was
taught and how the world was told to me
what story of the world I was given and
I had to think twice about who are those
people who told me that story and why
were they doing that and what story do I
now want to tell her how do I want to
interrupt that one
which is right at the heart of the
liberal Jewish political world but so
let me just say this though what I like
and what I need for me is so funny that
we were on different sides of a certain
kind of intellectual spectrum but now I
don't think I can think without him
sorry I didn't get to tell you yesterday
but what I get from him especially
reading about his own experiences being
attacked or being called anti-semitic or
people saying vile and hideous things
against this elegant brilliant erudite
reasonable person it really reasonable
person is that he says that the
intellectual who is yes always a public
intellectual in the sense that when we
publish were in the world and we put our
stuff out there we are exposed who knows
what's coming back or not coming back
it's a risk he says you have to
reconcile the demands of your own self
with the public demands upon you hmm and
that was helpful to me and he talks
about alertness as a kind of virtue of
the of the of the public intellectual or
the intellectual who is trying to
respond to a certain kind of public
demand or public situation um
he uses the word vulnerability he
doesn't use the word courage so much but
he was courageous and whenever that
struggle was to continue to speak out
and to say what he had to say even
though he was being viciously attacked
and people were trying to demean him
just as as we know Palestinian
professors here at Columbia who tried to
do scholarship on Palestine have also
been shamelessly attacked
I just want to emerge from the attack
how does one fend it off I mean you said
that people called you anti-semitic well
I don't know I bet you cared a little
long as the bullets didn't flow long as
the bullets didn't fly but don't you
kind of feel like the bullets are just
right behind that I mean are they that
far behind I've been called worse though
Andy I hear what I do hear what you're
saying it's not that I celebrated it or
anything but I knew given the discursive
terrain by saying these kinds of things
it was predictable that you would get
that kind of nonsense coming at you but
you just have to make sure that you in
no way are degrading Jewish brothers and
sisters as a whole when you're engaging
in a critique of a vicious Israeli
occupation and you make that severance
very clear in your work and your
speeches and so forth and you just move
on because you don't want it to pay
Elijah I mean you know I'd restate it I
said you know there's nothing
particularly anti-semitic by also taking
issue with Zionism as opposed to the to
the occupation which is really I felt
like the history to which he was really
returning to like telling that history
again and again in in the 40s and and in
the 50s and and what that meant for
displacement and for the stealing of
land but but you know what I what I
loved about the fact that he got so
viciously attacked I mean I hate the
fact that he got viciously attacked and
that these vicious attacks continue
still but what I appreciate is that he
seemed to get calmer and more rational
right he just went back he said okay
let's take the argument apart let's move
carefully it's good let's be more
careful let's be more precise let's
let's talk about it historically let's
talk about it conceptually let's use
some counter examples let's let's write
with absolute persuasive lucidity I
don't know I think I don't I don't know
how to fathom it but it's it's a it's a
great thing and it is it is it is
perhaps a kind of virtue I don't know I
don't think we can mime it or follow it
I mean it was his but we have to kind of
ask that question of ourselves how do we
take those risks and not become not
become a purveyor of aura of deodorized
discourse
not become a kind of pure professional
who cares only about professional
standing or who won't risk one's
reputation by speaking what one knows to
be true and unjust right with the
scholarly apparatus that will be
bringing yes
to it I mean I think for example of the
exchange between brother Edward and
brother Michael Walzer and that famous
essay it would wrote Exodus a Canaanite
perspective that Canaanite view what the
Exodus looked like from the vantage
point of the full court in the land of
milk and honey
they're already there like indigenous
peoples when Europeans arrived here and
then they were wonderful exchanging is
right down here in New York at The New
Yorker Hotel right near Madison Square
Garden by solo blue magic that night
before and you got Walzer and Zahid
going at it
and zayeed laying bare door critique of
an exodus narrative about liberation for
particular peoples and the subjugation
that followed therefrom and then walls
are saying well no Edward you are
enchanted by a romance weird the
isolated intellectual who valorizes
transgression that ends up with the
attention more on the isolated
intellectual van on the collective
insurgency of the people you're speaking
on behalf of now that was fascinating
because in one sense it's about what is
the role of tradition see Edward had a
modernist sensibility so he was very
suspicious of tradition in a certain
sense but then when you turn to after
the after the last sky which is one of
the great texts yeah on Palestinian
traditions of resistance traditions of
poetic expression traditions of
collective insurgency you say lo and
behold you're actually a little closer
to Edmund Burke than you think the Burke
who talks about tradition as inescapable
not a traditionalist understanding of
tradition but a transgressive subvert
if understanding of tradition that
generates traditions of resistance and
it was honest about that because when he
started talking about the Palestinian
question he had to dig deeper I remember
right across the street when he when he
published what he sent me to copy of
Orientalism before was published we
talked for two and a half hours and I
said brother Edward you have written a
text that will create a fissure in the
public discourse but my one criticism is
I don't hear the voices of those who
have been oriental eyes at the level
that I want you're so concerned about
the structure of the dominant discourse
they don't talk back enough they don't
respond enough and what is the tradition
people even in catastrophic situations
with melancholic spiritual conditions
oftentimes they steal right back
they resist politically spiritually
collectively and so for these things
spiritual that they create hip-hop is a
genre in a declining American Empire of
economic inequality political paralysis
cultural decay they still fight back and
he said mmm
think you got a point point brother with
think he got a point and he would listen
and he respond right back subsequent
tech Chomsky actually said the same
thing to him hmm
because he showed me Chomsky's letter
but we can't do everything in one text
and he knew that he said but in saying
that back to your point about the the
kind of a certain kind of secular
humanism tied to an individual
intellectual so that in that in the in
the the lectures there in London
representations of the intellectual
there it looks like he was going back to
a certain kind of isolating until after
he was talking very personally a very
person and then he come right back
in subsequent text and talk about
traditions resistance again so it's back
and for very complicated sometimes
contradictory never fully confused but
always created and challenging maybe
it's also important to remember that
there were those
important editorials that he was writing
in the Haram Arabic weekly and and
abdomen and that those tended to be
really very concrete about political
initiatives what was happening on the
ground what political parties were doing
who the brokers were what the stakes
were and that seemed to be a different
kind of writing right he was very very
very obviously attuned to to the
concrete political terms of the struggle
at that point I think maybe that would
have been the more effective rejoinder
to Mister will you call him brother
Walter but I can't quite do that no I
understand I don't know Uncle Michael
anyway but but in it and in those pieces
you know you get these devastating
critiques at PLO leadership yes it was
three weeks away he's at the distance
himself yeah dominant elements yeah in
the Palestinian now but you know there's
something about Exile maybe I'll just
say this and we can we can open it up
and but but um something about exile you
know at one point he says exile is a
concrete condition it's also a metaphor
okay in other words it is this
particular people dispossessed but first
of all we have to ask the question does
exile does it talk about does it
adequately were equally embrace
Palestinians with damaged rights within
the Israeli state currently does it
equally does it describe well
Palestinians living under occupation in
the West Bank or Gaza or in Gaza which I
consider to be a kind of you know under
siege may be a continuation of
occupation by other means does it do
those communities or those in and then
those who are intellectuals in New
Yorkers that the same as being in a
refugee camp in the south of Lebanon or
and and I just think maybe I'm not sure
exile can do all that work and I'm not
sure I can do all that work well
and when it's when it's both a condition
and a metaphor it's also not just the
condition of Palestinians let's remember
but the link between the Palestinians
and the native peoples and the Jews and
the Cypriots and the African Americans
and all the others he's willing to list
there at which point it's doing a whole
lot of work and and then you know the
other question so so where's belonging
where's belonging there's always a
longing to belong but what about
communities in which belonging is being
reproduced all the time right and he
does say that in after the last sky I
mean especially some of those
photographs of of people in their
domestic spaces continuing to lay the
table and continuing to go through the
rituals of everyday life that
consolidate a certain kind of tradition
and and history instead of connections
but but at the political level what are
what kind of forms of belonging are they
and and if he's against certain kinds of
nationalism how do we think about
belonging to the Palestinian nation
across these various scattered zones if
it's not a nationalism is there another
language for it would have been
interesting to push push push those
those questions about prolonging and
solidarity crucial push and then the
micro social institutions family
everyday and families assisted is
written this wonderful reflection on our
own life and so forth played a very
important role as I mentioned
universities very important I was
blessed to give a lecture in Northfield
Mount Hermon where he went to prep
school they still talking about him
there
Williams Panos and others who taught him
me because he was the brother was a
genius he's no doubt about early on you
can see it Blackmer told him that write
down that saw Street and Princeton
that's 1950 what you come out of
Princeton 57 50 something like that two
years after Ralph Nader my fanatical
which one but I mean in the mid-50s so
that he did have certain desire for long
and he didn't theorize that was micro
micro social innocence what nationhood
but family certainly friends my god
his loyalty to me and the revolutionary
could come with a calm his christian
revolutionary christian unbelievable and
anytime you mentioned christianity
edward you got it
turn away you know he came out of a
christian context from his grandparents
and so forth is it but he had his own
critiques and so forth but the loyalty
was so real it was genuine why we had
human connections we found out he had
leukemia I said brother I'm getting down
on my knees in your living room I
brought Reverend James Forbes and
Reverend James Washington three of us we
pray for him right there in September
1991 I'll never forget as long as I live
all of us had tears in our eyes he let
you he let you but he was circular he
was second he said you can fight this
one on your knees but I'm glad you're
down there but I'm circular not y'all
but he knew the love was being expressed
that's the important thing in that Nets
Michael social too as opposed to a
nation state or or a political party
it's a yeah so we got about 15 minutes
and we have I hold in my hand some
questions and just reminder to those of
you out there who might want to drop one
in in a couple minutes at CU palestine
hashtag edward saeed a question maybe to
shift into the present it's been a
remarkable journey and time set as you
said we speak of him in the present
tense but we've it's inevitable that
we've been looking backwards too there's
a question that says can you address how
to translate this debate into action
should we be concerned or how should we
be concerned with activism mmm-hmm well
there's one point in in edwards writings
when he says that he gives lecture
sometimes and then people stand up and
at the end and they say what should we
do and he he writes i refuse to answer
that question
because he didn't think it was the
proper purview of that of the
intellectual he understood the
intellectual to be causing discomfort
trying to point out inconsistencies
trying to produce different different
frameworks checking the facts making the
arguments elucidating it so I think that
what he didn't like was the idea that an
intellectual should be in the place of
the ruler and he says this and he
worries about how the discourse of rule
has saturated the intellectual right so
if we sit up here and go okay everybody
here are the five things we need you to
do right and then send you on your way
what kind of position are we in at that
moment I mean I have obviously several
you know we both have clear political
commitments that one contract but I
think I think one has to sort of you
know um respectfully resist the question
I'm going to get in trouble for that
honor though yeah I can see it now yes
not even I'm feeling impatient to get
that job under what let me just say this
guys there is a very important footnote
brother rush sheets text we talks about
on page 620 of the second volume of
Henry Kissinger's memoir he says America
has function as Israel's lawyer Israel's
lawyer that means that as American
citizens in our name the American
government has function in such a way
that it is not just hidden and concealed
as suffering but helped reproduce it in
more intense ways and as American
citizens who are concerned about truth
and the door'll are used to say what the
condition of truth is to allow suffering
to speak everybody's suffering anybody's
suffering we have a fundamental role to
tell the truth about the role of America
as the kind of broker of deceit that it
has been that's contrary to what
happened in March 1945 when the Franklin
Delano Roosevelt told the head of Saudi
Arabia Empire we will not proceed unless
we check with you and will
do-nothing hostile the Arab says March
1945 on the way from y'all topic and
every president has violated that
statement in a letter to the repressive
autocratic regimented Saudi Arabian
regime everyone so it's a matter of
trying to get that truth out honestly in
organized ways supporting the young
people that a lot of this will be a
crucial role will be played by the young
Jewish brothers and sisters who are
willing to tell the truth
visa via your mama's and your daddy's
that you refuse to live in an empire in
a democratic experiment that does not
treat other human beings with dignity
and decency in our name that's true for
the Philippines a true for Guatemala
it's true for the West but it's true for
Ethiopia too it's also true but we talk
about Palestine tonight so in that sense
it was saying I'm not going to tell you
one thing to do I agree I'm not gonna
tell you two things to do
I agree understand what is happening and
what is being done in your name and your
refusal to allow it to happen
to the best of your ability whatever
form it takes the filmmaker as a poet as
an artist as a professor as a chauffeur
Janet ation work or whatever it is
whatever form I guess I guess I would
just add one thing here which is that I
mean it's it's interesting that we are
two non Palestinians up here who are
addressing the issue of the public
intellectual but we have to make sure
that the absence of the Palestinian is
not a condition of legitimacy right so
the real question for me is what are we
hearing from Palestine what are what are
people in Palestine asking us to do is
there a call to us as there are requests
is there are there are there ways of
making solidarity with say the prisoners
solidarity movement I mean I noticed
that there was a solidarity between
prisoners in in Palestine and Pelican
Bay
eight that was important that was a
moving very interesting solidary
actually one that was initiated by the
Palestinian prisoner organizations
what's the boycott divestment and
sanctions movement asking us to do what
are they telling us about how our
institutions are complicit with the
reproduction of the occupation or the
sanitization of Zionism more generally
how do we respond to that call those are
two huge widespread civil movements in
Palestine and they they do they do ask
for certain kinds of solidarity and and
they do they do help help us orient
ourselves since we don't want to be over
here deciding what's the best thing to
do for Palestine right then we're
technocratic in intellectuals who are
divorced from a democratic struggle from
a struggle for self-determination right
from the outside if you're going to
decide what Palestine should do then
you're undercutting self-determination
and Palestine hasn't yet had
self-determination you know that's
that's the the least we can do is is is
here read what it is that is being asked
of us and make judgments about it surely
you know we don't just like whoa okay
anything no we make judgments about what
we can do how we can respond what's
what's that what's the ethical and
political call and how does it resonate
with me and what can I do from within my
position or from within my institution
within my religious institution within
my my family and although I'm extremely
pleased and honored to be with James
part of Jewish Voice for Peace which I
think has effectively made extraordinary
solid eristic with Palestinian
grassroots organizations especially the
boycott divestment and sanctions
movement I think we have to make sure it
doesn't just stay Jews and Palestinians
yes because the Solidarity is that
the edward envisioned were solidarities
among colonized people and an among the
forcibly exiled and so it's a it's a
broader kind of coalition right can't
just stay in that in that die attic in
that die attic frame absolutely very
good I must say and it was the most
elegant honoring of Edward Said's
injunction against talking about
activism by breaching it than I could
have imagined all right thank you we we
have two other questions that are
somewhat linked and they refer I think
at least for me back to that astonishing
quotation of Amish Robbie's dissertation
the last word of which was very
surprising to me when she talks about
this collective socio side and in both
bio and cultural death of all of these
various folks over over history and ends
with that this leads her to an
unprecedented and the word she is was
knowledge yeah because I was waiting for
unprecedented something and knowledge
was a surprise actually and a great one
two questions one's pretty depressing
hasn't Palestinian culture already gone
into oblivion the other connected to it
though
how should Palestinians connect their
suffering to the suffering of others
what is the role of allies I think we've
already addressed some of that mystery
Sorensen of allies it's funny I have to
overcome my temptation to be slightly
rude in relation to the to the question
and I feel like maybe you could take it
I think I think rudeness has a rule I
know it does okay I'll get there
no look I mean first of all what we mean
by Palestinian culture I mean it
certainly is if you go to Palestine you
is not it is not a place of oblivion it
is an active interesting place where
people arguing with each other law and
making excellent food and doing many
other things in life so you know are we
talking about inmates in the mainstream
media has it perhaps become a lost or
has it has it gone the way of oblivion
maybe but then we have to shift the
frame right I mean and that's one of the
things he Edward was asking us to do
shift the frame like something is
radically absent in the dominant media
but where is it present and what are the
alternate media's that are making it
present and which are which are
producing a kind of counter hegemonic
resistance and he actually had some real
interest in the internet as a site that
could disrupt say the dominant media non
representation or reductive
representation either terrorist or
absent end and I think um so I guess
that's one thing I'm the other point is
that I think there are different forms
of global solidarity some of them are
focused on international law and it's
its abrogation and others are about
resistance movements or allies among
colonized people I've noted as well that
there's some really interesting
connections between first world peoples
and and Palestinians on the question of
indigeneity how to think about self-rule
how to make the claim for self-rule how
not to replicate certain forms of state
sovereignty people don't seem to like
but still honor ideas of political
self-determination or self-rule those
are those are live questions those are
those are intense important questions
and one can't think them alone one can't
think them alone in this one moment
where he's talking about a door no he
says it's
it's not possible he's citing a don't
Adorno to the effect that no one can
have a cogent thought without that
thought being thought elsewhere in other
words it has to be thought somewhere
else in order for it to be cogent here
it can't just be my private thought it
has to be something someone else can
think or has thought or something I can
think with others which means not just
within this framework but you know it
you know in a comparative framework and
he was a comparative literature
professor right and and and he made the
case for comparative diasporas and I
think we could on the basis of his work
also make a case for comparative
genocide which doesn't mean all
genocides are the same but it does mean
that we have to develop those kinds of
frameworks that are not just about
thinking how these catastrophes happen
in different times and spaces but what
kinds of alliances they foster and and
even eventually or implicitly what kind
of political solidarity that might lead
to let me just say a quick word about
this question though because it the
question for me is about memory
it's about visibility we live in a
neoliberal capitalist society that's
obsessed with three processes financial
izing privatizing and militarizing
highly financial of financialized
economy 42% of the profits go to big
banks thirty years ago they went to
corporations privatizing education
prisons right across the board
militarizing Imperial tentacles drones
US drones dropped on innocent people
AFRICOM we can go on and on and on you
see in such a context there's relatively
ratio of memory and a marginalizing of
certain kind of visibility so you take
the Palestinian catastrophe and the
memory of it within an American regime
of financial izing privatizing and
militarizing you're hardly hearing they
talk about the head of the American
Empire can go to United Nations and give
a whole speech and not say one mumbling
word about Palestinian brothers
and he's got the world looking at him
billions and billions he goes to the
White House doesn't say a mumbling word
about it visa beating head of the
Israeli regime and that's what you get
on Fox News MSNBC the right-wing version
and the neoliberal wing version so
narrow so truncated so often vacuous
that memory drops out visibility drops
of people when are the Palestinians are
they still there in Gaza you don't say
what are they doing God what do you got
a lot of creativity going on as you
rightly say but how would people get
access to it other than social media
which is also privatized in its own way
but privatization can be used against
privatization we know that we could be
dialectical about it in that way but the
other but the dominant orientation the
dominant gaze to you that language is
within a neoliberal capitalist regime
that makes it difficult for that's why
we don't hear any talk about memory of
the million Filipinos who were killed by
US imperial forces in the 1890s anybody
made a film about that
anybody got discourse about that now
it's probably half that's right I'm
gonna try you do it brother
do what if they don't get me a new one
but but all I'm saying is that it was so
selective given the ideological
criterias in light of the larger
structure even though the choices that
we make still make a difference I mean
I'm whatever it on this agency still
makes a difference all right so I'm just
going to add to that one thing which is
that deal liberalism has certainly
arrived in Palestine in the sense that
all those all those neoliberal metrics
have entered into the non-governmental
organizations who are helping to keep
universities alive who are who are
helping to establish irrigation who are
working throughout the infrastructure
right so one of the things that happens
is that the infrastructure of course
gets bombed or destroyed and then the
NGOs come in with their neoliberal
metrics and rebuild it and it's a it's a
cycle right and one of the problems with
it is that you don't actually think
about well what is it
is actually undermining the
infrastructural conditions of Palestine
systematically what are those policies
and how is that how has the Israeli
state in imposed them and then the if
but if we're only trying to ameliorate
the effects through a certain cut and we
can we can measure them according to
neoliberal metrics like people are
functioning better or they're able to
get to whatever their worksite is if
they have a worksite or whatever that is
we're actually producing a kind of
rationality that is complicit with the
occupation even though it's trying to
ameliorate its effect so neoliberalism
has definitely arrived and it seems to
me also to undercut these basic
questions of self-determination which I
keep coming back to what would it be to
build those institutions in ways that
the Palestinian people would like and to
have them sustainable on the basis of
that of that populations desires so
we're wrapping up okay so this is your
last chance to be embarrassing contrary
you're rude oh yeah but if there's any
one minute really it's 8:30 if there's a
final thought you'd like to share with
us tonight before we leave I just want
to say I'm really thrilled to be here
with with Cornel West he's one of my
favorite interlocutors and I have when I
say one of them I mean actually that the
conversation with him is like no other
in the world and I treasure it every
time treasured every time and I'm just
I'm just as happy as I could possibly be
no right back at my dear sister one last
word don't
that when you think of the towering
public in elections the term I don't
like I like the term Democratic
intellectual but the empowering public
intellectuals in the American Empire the
twentieth century John Dewey Columbia WB
Dubois
for his part twentieth century you see
Edward Wilson and then we can have some
others then here comes Edward he is
committed to a notion of the public
there are some contenders James Baldwin
is Susan Sontag and some others but
Edward is committed to the pub but he
arrives at a time when the neoliberal
regime which is in the early 70s is
becoming more popular and becomes
hegemonic by the late 80s by by the mid
mid late 80s even under conservative
auspices of Reagan is still neoliberal
in terms of being capitalist tied to
those three tendencies so he has to cut
even more radically against the grain
when the voice invokes public and Dewey
invokes public people have a memory in
the sensitive public the New Deal was
real the Roosevelt did commit class
suicide against his well-to-do Hyde Park
friends but by the time you get to the
80s the notions of the public become
more and more elusive father removed
from memory so he has to be even more
heroic and then he's Palestinian oh my
god I mean the notion that the greatest
public intellectual in American
everybody let afford to innocence would
be a Palestinian just think about that
but it's true is true but as a
Palestinian he's just not every
Palestinian he's somebody who is as
highbrow sophisticated refined creative
also has his limitations but he's
courageous open-minded self-critical and
willing to bear witness in such a way
that ten years later we could come to
the same spot that even Lexington
Russell would for forty years and still
be on fire like he was because he was
always
on fire love that about mother but love
that about it brings tears to my eyes
and you thinking about all this energy
that he but dispenser
how can he do so much in so little time
he didn't have computers in the same the
flights took more hours think of the
level of sacrifice that took when he
found out he had leukemia in September
1991 he didn't stop his brother mezack
was telling me that he saw Edward give a
lecture in the afternoon after having
chemotherapy that the chemotherapy that
morning and he had more energy he had
ever seen of any intellectual behind the
lectern that's the kind of commitment
that brother had Edwards I we love you
brother Edward we'll never forget you
okay well I think any worse I ever say I
remember that